[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i know one thing
wherever we go
this family
[Music]
here's our fortress
[Music]
kids get to popcorn now let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to godbod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only thor
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's the family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take
am i um sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
it's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
[Music]
you
are not like the other gods that kill
them
because i have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flicked too hard damn it
should we help him then eventually great
[Music]
life there was like a frozen river
[Music]
the surface was beautiful
but underneath
it's a joyless and a lonely life
but you
you are different
[Applause]
that's where
you can change everything
[Music]
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
i saw a sign in the sky
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
there's something out there i'm talking
about you
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
[Music]
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it knows how to hunt
i know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever did this
i can kill it
[Applause]
[Music]
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
my son sacrificed his life to save me
[Music]
their heroes
well i do
my vision has shown me the future
you have two choices you can be the
destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
behind you
did he just catch a rocket
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking about uh no one you
were narrating again i was not just
doing the mission log you do know no one
ever listens to that i know that
narrating helps me focus
ready captain let you ready as i'll ever
be commander hawthorne this is exciting
a new adventure i'm gonna grant you four
minutes to be off planet but then you
come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz lightyear to star command come in
star command
why don't they answer
hey
the robots the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone
62 years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship i have a plan and
i have a team darby can take any three
things and make them explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was gonna be like a
fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
you know what i'm saying the harpoons
[Music]
right here
[Music]
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 hmm seems a
bit low
mission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
too
there was a big swelling too i think i
need a better oh no please record your
last words do not vomit inside the
vehicle do not vomit inside the vehicle
if you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
[Music]
what if i told you
that
today leave here
different
wow
i'm talking
to you
bro what'd you see someone above the
clouds that's big i'll be big
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
[Music]
right here
you
are gonna witness
an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
are you ready
[Music]
here we go
this could be an opportunity i'm talking
rich and famous for life there's plenty
of videos for flying [ __ ] online ain't
nobody gonna get what we gonna get what
are we gonna get the money shot what's
up undeniable proof of aliens on camera
the oprah shot
you guys gonna tell me what's going on
hell no
there's something out here are you the
only person in the world that can get it
on film
that cloud a movement it's aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
i'll be rooting for you
i think we pissed them off
they repainted your house
they gonna come back
you ready
we got some work to do
nope i'll get him out
and i'll get the shot let's go baby
let's go
i need y'all to tell me what did you see
in that cloud
was not what you think
they took me
they took them all
i gotta get out this house i'm trying to
save you my brother is out there
i don't think they thank you
if you don't look at it
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
five stars angel five stars
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this fog is toxic
commander vector ground
can anybody hear me
[Music]
if anyone else is out there please
answer
[Music]
how long can we stay up here growing old
here
never seeing earth what kind of a life
is that we
[Applause]
[Music]
it could blow up any seconds
[Music]
there's no shame in caring for your own
life hannah
i can feel you pulling things around in
there
it's a brand new organ
never before seen
[Music]
we've all felt that the body was empty
empty of meaning
and we've wanted to confirm that
so that we could fill it with meaning
[Music]
the world is a much more
dangerous place now that pain has all
but disappeared
[Music]
surgery is sex isn't it
[Music]
i don't like what's happening with the
body
in particular what's happening with my
body
which is why i keep cutting it up
what do you think they'd find inside
outer space
[Music]
sorry
let us not be afraid to map the chaos
inside
[Music]
let us create a map
that will guide us
into the heart of darkness
[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
i promise you i am gonna get her back
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
here
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i can use your expertise
you comment or what
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah what
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
what is
see not so bad
[Music]
every night
i dreamed the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you cannot control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look up
become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
that doesn't seem fair
right
[Music]
[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying attention
now you may only see a pile of receipts
but i see a story
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
[Music]
if i'm from another universe i'm here
because we need your help
[Music]
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
i've seen thousands of
you can evelyn's
all the memories their emotions
even the skills
there's a great evil spreading the many
verses
and you
maybe your only chance of stopping it
don't make me [ __ ] you i am really good
i don't believe you
the universe he speaks of senseless
things is so much bigger
than you realize
of all the places i could be
i just want you to share with you
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
multiverse
there is no way i am the evelyn you are
looking for
anything distract you from it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what threatened us with catastrophe
turned out to be our salvation
the new history of mankind begins here
in these very minutes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
and the earth was cycles and empty
and the darkness
over the abyss
[Applause]
oatmeal latte light foam
hey
how's uh the mars boyfriend long
distance dating sucks how long have you
guys been together eight years eight
years how did you manage that he checks
all the boxes oh you mean literally
strong jaw mental fortitude six pack
we had a plan and then he got his
martian dream job
so i enrolled in the mars program
you ever worry the wrong person is
headed to the wrong planet goodbye
forever walt
five
four
three
two
what are you doing here who sneaks onto
spaceships i can explain
ever since i was a kid i've dreamt of
going to mars
you can keep my dream alive come with me
you cannot under any circumstances leave
my room okay
this is gonna suck isn't it only for 35
days
you have to keep a low profile
right you guys i'm your captain this is
sophie my girlfriend long-term
girlfriend i don't remember you from
orientation
what happened
you have to come right back and just rip
his jumpsuit off
hey what's up i just miss you sorry do
we have a call scheduled
come on let's go have some fun i don't
do fun you also don't fly on rockets or
conspire with stowaways sophie for walt
disney 100 bucks since you just said
that in your wrist
just got to face it you're a space
criminal now
historic journey to make life more
meaningful
now that is a story people want to hear
you've spent your entire life trying to
check an impossible set of foxes
i can't risk the plan can you find that
thing that you're willing to cross the
entire universe to be with
make sure it's ready to do the same for
you
[Music]
it doesn't matter how far you travel
you can never escape yourself did you
just come up with that
no [ __ ] that is a very common phrase
[Music]
prepare yourself for a journey beyond
what is possible walt disney animation
studios proudly presents strange world a
new motion picture event price yourself
travel past space and time to a place of
infinite mystery unlike anything you've
ever seen
where in the world are we
[Music]
what in uh
[Music]
i'm not an explorer i'm a farmer
[Music]
we need to get out of here
if you want to back out this is the time
to do it
really
no
messing with you come on let's make
history
[Music]
all right tv night with my pro
you're going on a date with lois so
disrespectful
oh hey there little fella
wake up buddy it is i have an owner
he's superman
[Music]
like a melody my dog is the best
but he's not the greatest with other
animals this just seems gross we need
gross smelling stuff is one of the
greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body and i lick
myself all the time well that explains
the breath
superman i am lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
[Music]
you're invulnerable i should be a lot
more dead right now right all of us have
superpowers
still working out the kinks i didn't see
anything
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs sasha never feed us
chocolate we love unconditionally
we're just a bunch of shelter pets
but we're stronger than you think
we'll help you get your dumbo on the
back
hey deploy canines here what is a k-9
[Music]
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
why can't i have gotten a magic hammer
or something
what do i have here
oh squeezy bruce
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]
[Music]
i
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
oh
[Music]
tell me something
[Music]
you can go
anywhere you want
right any timeline
and the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the path
are you in
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
you